[Musique]
1793 en 360 ans d'histoire notre î a
changé plusieurs fois de nom
cartographié par les navigateurs arabes
comme Dina morgabine signifiant l'île de
l'ouest elle est baptisée Santa Polonia
par les Portugais du nom de la sainte du
jour de sa découverte au début du 16e
siècle aussi au portugais Pedro de
mascarenas que l'on doit le nom de
mascargne pour désigner l'archipel
composé des actuelles îles de La Réunion
Maurice et Rodrig les premiers
navigateurs anglais la désignent comme
Pearl Island ou encore England forest à
cause de sa luxueuse végétation les
Français qui l'a dénommé Mascarin
officialisent le terme d'î Bourbon lors
d'une prise de possession symbolique en
1649 la Révolution française après la
capitation de Louis XV décide de changer
le nom de l'île le 19 mars
1793 Monge mathématicien devenu ministre
de la marine fait voter le nom d'î de la
réunion ce choix s'explique certainement
par la situation du pays alors en proie
à des divisions terribles de toutes
parts peu après le sacre de Napoléon
l'île est nommée Bonaparte en 1806 mais
la prise de possession par les Anglais
en 1810 entraîne le our du nom île
Bourbon ce n'est qu'en 1848 avec la 2e
République que l'île redevient la
Réunion
1793 l'île Bourbon devient la
[Musique]
Réunion